Speaker 1: OK, let me start with a follow
up about a story from yesterday.
Yesterday, I showed you the video of this
coughing anti mask woman in a grocery store
in Nebraska.
We did not yet have that much information
about her yesterday.
Now we know much more about her and she has
been fired.
Her name is Janine Moscovitch.
This is an Arizona woman who used to work
for the software company SJP.
She has been fired.
She was in a video that has gone Gigha viral,
I would call it, coughing on a mother and
daughter who were shopping at a supersaver
grocery store in Lincoln, Nebraska.
She's done, folks.
Let's review the video first just so we're
all on the same page.
This is from yesterday and it is horrifying.
Unidentified: If you excuse me, I'm coming
through.
Viall.
While it's happening, she's coughing up no,
you guys.
OK, whatever your.
Why don't you have a laugh, because I don't
need to have one on.
And neither are you.
Speaker 1: How does she know you don't know
this or not?
Speaker 3: My allergy.
You are not very friendly.
Oh, you got.
Yeah.
And so two years ago, before anybody started
talking about covid, you were OK with going
out, not knowing you were.
Speaker 1: You don't want my help.
I Joe.
Janine, can you deploy those new updates to
the code, please?
Speaker 3: I have the energy and she got all
freaked out.
I'm confused.
You know, she she just said, I don't know
anything about her.
You don't know anything about my health.
I actually maybe I have
Speaker 1: a funny 30 seconds prior.
She says we don't need masks because I'm not
sick and neither are you.
And then she says, you don't know anything
about my health or her health already, but
nobody knows anything.
OK, so listen, she has been fired.
She has been fired.
S&P, the company that she used to work for,
put out a statement after the woman was identified
saying, quote, The health and safety of our
employees and the communities in which we
live and work are of utmost concern to us.
We are taking the matter of an S&P employee
incident very seriously and investigating
the situation going on to say via Twitter,
we have reviewed the incident and can confirm
that the individual in question no longer
works for S&P.
This is, of course, the right decision for
S&P as a business.
They made the decision that was best for them.
And Janina's Kovik now can go and participate
in the marketplace of employment and of ideas.
And there may well be a company that will
hire her because of this unhinged coughing
rant or not.
And that would be the marketplace of ideas
and employment that the right so desperately
claims to want.
So that is one follow up.
That is a very, very good thing.
And no word on charges yet.
We did talk yesterday about how under Nebraska
law.
One, a layman's interpretation of third degree
assault suggests that this could be third
degree assault.
That's one thing.
In addition, in times of covid, one could
argue that federal terrorism charges could
actually be levied against folks like this
for deliberate coughing on others.
I don't think we've seen it, but that was
a legal opinion that was floated a few months
ago.
We looked at a Forbes article yesterday that
explained it.
As of yet, no charges that we know of against
Jeanine Skarbek, certainly being judged in
the court of public opinion as the video has
been viewed.
I mean, the original post was viewed more
than four million times, but it's been replicated
and duped.
That's just on Twitter between all of the
reposts to YouTube and Facebook.
I assume at least 20 million people have seen
this over the last 48 hours.
So that's going on.